i don't know who he just did ellen yeah
i just did it ellen and last night i was
doing kimmel it's just been like a long
like world war is ellen even still on
i didn't do ellen but um i'm about to
say yeah you don't look like a i did the
real which was fun the real yeah ever
heard lonnie love i love lonnie she's
the best all right we'll talk about it
in a second
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen once again second
try welcome to ripon with griffin
your absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
all right
ladies and gentlemen uh we haven't had a
guest in a while but you know when we
have a guest
we like to give them to sing them i can
see what they can do so johnny he's
always terrible
yeah
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
okay okay
griffin with griffin probably your
fourth favorite pod
that's all i had
give me my goddamn singing mic
[Music]
thank you liquid iv for sponsoring this
episode grab your favorite liquid iv
flavors nationwide at walmart or you can
get 25 off when you go to liquidive.com
and use code griffin at checkout that's
25 off anything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
griffin at
liquidive.com you know what it's a
little scary wearing uh headphones at
jeremiah watkins war you know what i
mean yeah you can take them off
uh i feel like
i wonder if i should take mine off so i
can hear the sound and uh you know it
will be fine just make sure you talk
into the mic all right i mean oh there
we go yeah it sounds good like
like i'm doing this all by myself
because my guy isn't here today but um i
expected more of you being on a black
shell you know what i'm saying i should
have prepared something
i expected a little bit more it's so
cool like i'll be in my living room and
i can actually kind of do something and
then you go and there's like some type
of pressure and you're like oh it
[ __ ] folded uh that's why like when
you see those people going like hot 97
i'm like okay that was pretty funny i
know what you mean though yeah yeah like
a little dicky or something yeah it's
it's insane it puts it into perspective
um welcome back uh i'm not gonna even
try to do your last name
because i always mess it up it's all
good payolo
the last time i was on here was what two
years ago yeah that's what i was about
to say so the last time you here you
were just like an intern for theo and i
didn't know who you were you were just
it was weird you know then the fact you
even had a publicist that i know and i
was like why don't you have a publicist
because i had a big movie coming out
that's why well right yeah but he was
still you know why are you doing this
other thing
and then now you're on instagram with
aston martin
being a just a a douche
i'd say you're at a gas station with an
aston martin like oh humble brands oh
supreme guys
yeah
i gotta get the unleaded like
i was like so what congratulations to
you huh
you're moving up in the world since what
was the name of that movie mom yeah mom
it was mom yeah i actually saw that i
actually really enjoyed it you liked it
it was fun right yes i think we're
trying to do another one but she was
really good and like you know when she
ran that lady over yeah
you know just how casual anyways it was
good she's so good yeah yeah she was
really it was actually a really good
movie so congrats to you thank you but
your big thing is being white chocolate
on yeah that's why i had to come you
know hit the eric griffin audience real
quick little half and half you know all
hundred of them um
so yeah so you're like so let's just get
to the business part of it yeah because
you have a cause you're on a sp is it a
spin-off yeah just forgive me i i wasn't
a power person no it's all good i'm an
empire guy
oh wow
wow did you did you watch the jesse
smellette trial was that like the finale
episode for you guys yeah it really was
um how crazy is that yeah it doesn't
it's why i still don't i still don't
know i didn't even look into the details
of everything either because it just is
so like mind-boggling i'm like if i if
if i read this and take the time it's
just gonna [ __ ] piss me off you know
the thing is is like when you when i
think about that i think about like how
the news cycle goes fast i didn't even
know there was a trial coming i thought
yeah neither i thought he was out of the
news i agree it's so funny i thought the
same thing then when i saw this thing i
was like what are they talking to him
for yeah i was like i thought he was in
jail yeah yeah i thought he like paid a
fine or whatever happened so now
apparently that's still a thing so who
knows with that that's just like when
that first happened theo released a
video the next day being like this guy's
lying all this stuff and i remember
being like dio do not put this out like
he's literally like calling him out
being this guy's lying there's no way
this happened he's like that doesn't
make sense he like read all the things
and then like 48 hours later it came out
he's lying i was like damn theo had his
that was that was risky you know what my
biggest my biggest thing about that and
then we'll get back to you is the fact
that i'm glad that that happened yeah
because what jesse smollette did
was weaponize woke culture agreed agreed
he weapons yeah what you could do with
it he weaponized culture and these
idiots out there even some of my friends
they're on twitter i can't believe that
these things happen and they're tweeting
and they're like they're giving it all
this
thing with there's there's there's still
some people that are tweeting i still
stand with jesse small exactly are you
okay so he took advantage of that he
took advantage of that and and then it
all the evidence came out and then none
of those people were like exactly yeah
my bad yeah well it's the same thing
with um due process yeah it's remember
due process it's the same thing with
like what happens with when it's come
out with like women who have faked
allegations against men it's like it
takes away from what actually what
racism does exist in the country
exactly because then move forward bit
because then people are like oh well you
know the jesse smart thing happened so
maybe this is fake too it's like it just
takes away from everything yeah it takes
away yourself it's a selfish [ __ ]
thing to do well i mean the thing is
like what goes on the internet and then
what goes on in actual court are two
different things yeah like you know when
you like first of all our our idea of
like the law is like law and order yeah
and these kind of things yeah so then we
see these things and we like think that
we know what charges are and then when
you look in real life and you see that
there are like a multitude of charges
that someone can have
and then they see like oh he got
dismissed that why did he get dismissed
that it's like because they want to get
him on this other thing so they're not
yeah it's like you're never going to
understand it
but i will say i do stand with kyle
rittenhouse no i'm carrying my
the title of this is gianni stands with
kyle written house stop i'm kidding i'm
sure it's gonna be picture you and him
and i'm gonna be like this
[Music]
it's fine don't worry this is all just
she's time coding it that's it yeah
oh my god
this is going out today so
whatever you want to tell you but tell
me right away but anyways you're on
power it's a spin-off yeah i originally
did
you're originally on power which i was
like really surprised but i guess they
got to have some white boys on there but
you're the kind of white boy though
because you're italian yeah so like
that's like not like so you got surfer
like white white over here yeah and then
you got like i'm not wearing like
[ __ ] clogs
you got some you got a little soul in
you i can see you dating a black woman
yeah um but then here you are and you're
on it but it's the show is great it's
like very popular right you got an aston
martin so things are good
and a porsche forget about the portion
of new york right now i put up your like
financials are on the screen yeah it's
like right here it's like is that he
probably makes this much an episode um
10 goes to his manager by the way before
we even i'm starting you know he gets a
call from like a girl oh my god were you
on the view
i even turned down the volume i was like
i don't want to make eric feel too bad
i don't feel bad i'm securing myself but
i'm just looking like this this is how
it is yeah so tell me the difference two
years ago when you were just kind of
like you're on you're doing some stuff
yeah and then now
how are you how are you not transforming
into a [ __ ] boy go
um i'm gonna say the most fuckboy thing
ever but it's just like i've always had
that's the same mentality nothing has
changed i know
you can't talk about anything real or
motivational with eric because he's like
i don't believe you yeah no i believe
you yeah i always have had the same
mindset so i was like i knew i was going
to be here i know i'm going to be
further in two years so it's just i
don't feel any different self-confidence
you're confident in yourself and i just
log into my wells fargo and there's a
lot more money that's like all their
word i know what you mean i i remember i
know that feeling yeah i know this place
i can see that you're moving up in the
world eric is lying he lives in a
[ __ ] six-bedroom mansion
in bel air okay
you think i'd be doing a podcaster
i guess i would if it was like joe rogan
yeah kevin hart does a podcast i know i
know i know what am i saying what am i
talking about no but i mean i think that
your life is different you know i could
like i said i'm sure you get those like
i like how many calls have you gotten
from
the
the girls say
four years ago who were just kind of
like oh hi
we're now calling you like oh my god i
can talk to you in so long how are you
how are you you know i always liked you
you know i always i knew you were gonna
make it how many of those calls are you
getting it's literally still the same it
doesn't feel different to me like it's
different shut up it doesn't feel
different though
maybe it is different but i it just
honestly does not feel different like i
don't you just dealt with the decision
yeah yeah you know
they can hear me eric it's all good i
don't know because i don't go
but nobody on the sound board actually
let me just get my headphones just to
check on him for a little while then
i'll take him off hello okay yeah we're
good this sounds good yeah um yeah but
all right so but tell me about power the
new one cause it's called power what
power book two so people are like power
book
it's is it power go it's like it's power
it's the second book so book two ghost
is the one then there's ghost and they
have power book three raising kanan
which is a prequel so they're doing
other stuff with it which is smart i
mean you know they have a it's a huge
audience so well you know you know what
i think this is you know who i i think
this is gonna sound weird mm-hmm but i'm
gonna tell you
like where this all started
harry potter okay okay i'll explain why
okay so the harry 50 cent was watching
saucer stone one night he's like [ __ ]
yeah i know i got an idea can i see who
are you now all right
my bad what's the worst that's the worst
um
they did they had the movies so they
were booked they were making the movies
for book seven
they decided let's split this into two
yeah all right then that started it all
and then it was like hunger games all
right and then
the marvel universe is was really where
this is they were like you know what why
are we
why are we uh stopping here yeah let's
keep going why don't we stop here why
don't we connect all the universes and
then they did it for star wars so you
had this rich universe of star wars and
they and they said why are we finished
yeah actually let's show prequels let's
show han solo's story let's show and so
that became a thing where
i think all of society now when we look
at movies we're starting to go
hey what else is happening in this
universe and why why kill the universe
why not just keep it going you're a big
marvel guy so obviously you see that the
spider-mans are coming out they have
i don't understand how there's three
spider-mans in
one movie okay you didn't see the
cartoon
oh the spider-verse one you didn't see
that well that's what okay i need to
that was so successful because it was
about a multiverse okay oh i see yeah
okay that makes sense yeah it's a
multiverse and then uh and then i just
thought andrew garfield was going to
show up and be like oh you took my job
like i didn't know what well but i'm
sure he was so happy to come back so
it's basically saying that all those
universes
existed
and then it's like and i think that's
great because the move that's what the
cartoon was about it was very successful
there was like a bunch of spider-man's
okay you ever wonder why in the cartoon
this spider-man is black you know what i
mean because it's a multiverse yeah
another one it's a woman and it's 20-21
right right
you know what i mean
also transgender
yeah yeah yeah so they like but i'm
saying so like i see why other um
other stories productions are like you
know what we have this universe of power
yeah let's just keep going with it they
could just you know back stories you
know prequels sequels you know
it makes sense yeah so it's like it's a
money grab and it's like and but also
the people are interested in it so yeah
yeah but so tell me about what you even
do in it then we could just like talk
about whatever yeah no i just uh like i
always make this joke like the way i
look i should be on [ __ ] twilight but
i get to murder and kill and deal drugs
and do all that stuff so um i play a
drug dealer in college uh with two look
like that i can believe that yeah it's
not yeah it's not like too far off um
but brother would be better my little
brother oh my god dude he's [ __ ] that
ki he is a drug dealer he's [ __ ] he's
selling vivants on the side he's [ __ ]
out of his mind
um
but yeah it's just it's been fun like i
get to be on a show that i actually love
showing up to do work like i'm not
putting on a [ __ ]
fangs and do you know what i mean which
i would like to do that someday but like
i'm gonna point right now in my life
this is [ __ ] cool you just messed up
it's popular there's a vampire director
right now that's looking for you no
listen listen i was
i love twilight but right now was like a
25 year old guy i'm like it's i'm on the
cool show like i'm on the show that like
the shade room and complex and double xl
magazine you know like all those
we get that kind of press all the people
i looked up to growing up well this is
why you need to save your money why is
that because you're not always going to
be able to make that choice so right now
you're in a good spot you're on this
show hold on i'm getting another comment
that's my aston martin guy i got another
one coming in
exactly you're spending all your money
on that stuff then the show ends yeah
and then you're like ooh
what am i going to do
then the vampire movie comes yeah you're
going to be a
[Music]
gay vampire who has to do this and this
and you're going gonna be like oh you
have standards and then your
accountant's gonna be like you need
money
and then you're gonna like you're not
gonna be in the godfather four you know
what i mean yeah okay that's fair but
that's just an old guy talking yeah yeah
but you live in yo you live in your best
life yeah right yeah it's like what's
the point of how you know if you can
have fun i don't know what the yeah but
so i mean it's so interesting that that
that how different it is when you when
you're like i was looking at this thing
and it was saying like when you get
older um
you
you you'd lose you lose that like
whimsical
like just going for it yeah like this
kind of like you know then you just
become everything becomes like oh yeah
you have to make it
then i started to think about that it's
like am i like that and i don't want to
be like yeah that's that you know it's
funny that you say that because that's
what i don't want to be i don't want to
be the guy that's like okay i have this
away in case this show goes away it's
like no i'm just going to keep this
train rolling and then if something
happened then i'll reassess i think it's
a middle ground yeah i just think it's a
middle ground there's a middle ground of
being like responsible yeah yeah and
still have you still having fun and
doing your thing i'm not buying three
aston martins it's like i got two and
it's like it's gonna be i'm gonna be
reasonable about it you know listen
you're 25 you're young you're
good-looking you're on a show it's like
no you do you need to be in a toyota
celica yeah yeah yeah you know what i
mean like it's okay you live in your
best life yeah you know what i mean and
but someone i'm just looking from a
different perspective where i'm just
like okay
you know i'm about to get married i
started really late in life yeah so i'm
like now i got to be like oh this money
i have has to have to think about this
and that and that and i just go oh man
is there something negative about that
or is it something it's definitely a
matter it's definitely a mindset where
if you have this it's rolling it's wrong
it's rolling
i think it keeps rolling i think like
it's it's a an object in motion stays
emotion you're confident you do things
differently you approach people
differently you talk to people
differently if you come with this like
it's gonna it's gonna keep going if you
come with this oh it's gonna be
calculated you go to party and you're
like okay well i have to spend this
amount of money and this is what i have
to do and i have to talk that's an
extreme so you've never seen the 30 30
then about nfl football players well
yeah they do all lose their money with
all their money yeah uh you think that
you
you think actors but here's the things
aren't doing the same thing but here's
the thing with football players their
career is over they can no longer make
money doing football with acting you uh
there's tons of jobs that are all you
know what i mean i could do something
else i could probably name like
10 15 actors so you thought there's no
way they're not going to keep working
he's the first one who's the first one
remember the guy from this show and that
show and this movie and all that i mean
you know maybe they were too
conservative maybe they didn't
maybe they didn't fall out maybe they
didn't get a montclair you know this is
just
such a this is such this actually should
have been on my other podcast jen the
gentleman yeah this is definitely a
generational thing because i am not
against like i'm not going to sit here
and be like the uncle
yeah but i do feel like that it's so
it's okay to have like say a 401k plan
yeah no i have that listen i have an
investment portfolio yeah it's okay for
you to be like that's what that is yeah
what that is is like it's okay for you
to say okay i'm put such a such amount
of money away and never think about it
again and then then you have like a fund
that you're just like this is my rainy
day this is my nonsense account so you
have a nonsense account don't make your
nonsense account your main account yeah
okay
you're making it seem like i showed up
here in four rolexes in chains and i'm
like yo what the [ __ ] good eric like
no like i
my driver's outside but that's a
different story okay i don't want to put
the miles on the aston martin you know
what i mean i don't want to make it i
don't want to be a party poop i don't
want to be that i don't want to be the
grinch that stole you know
being young and dumb yeah you know what
i mean be young and dumb because you
only get to be young once exactly you
know what i mean because then when
you're old because i feel like i want to
be old and dumb you know i just bought a
a hydro machine down there one of these
rowan's oh i saw that i'm trying to like
you know i was like it was expensive i
tried to get them to give them one for
free i just don't got it like that yeah
but it's like sometimes you just do
things i went on vacation you know yeah
you got to live your life you know so
there's a middle ground there that i i
appreciate yeah yeah and if my show gets
canceled then i'm i'm gonna sleep in
your guest rooms oh my god no but i mean
but the thing is it's like but you as
long as you have that goat the go get
them like you're moving forward you're
setting yourself up you're building
relationships i mean that's what it's
all about so that's that go-getter
attitude that you're talking about yeah
right like just go get them go get them
go get them but you know again you just
there's just a balance you know that's
all i say that's the old my only advice
and i'm glad to hear that you're like
you're putting money away
yeah
yeah yeah you know because by the way
too you never know when there's going to
be a covid
agreed i have took it taken that into
consideration because that was crazy
when that happened i'm like oh yeah but
if i was talking about this before cody
yeah i think what the [ __ ] are you
talking about yeah yeah
they canceled then everything stops and
there's no money coming in and then what
i never thought anything could stop the
entertainment business crazy right i
never thought anything could stop it
yeah and then and then this thing
happened and i was sitting here like who
am i yeah like you know when you're when
that happens you go like am i like could
you define yourself by what you do
exactly and then you're just like when
you can't do what you do anymore who are
you yeah and then you have to like find
a way to redefine it and all this kind
of stuff my whole time i was just like
uh i can't wait to go back to work
because we didn't even finish season one
the whole time was just waiting to go
back to work oh you saw your date
already started the ghost yeah we were
on episode eight or nine oh and they had
started releasing episodes before we
even finished yeah oh no it was a
[ __ ] nightmare but then like did you
are you oh so what happened in that year
like did you like lose weight gain
weight did everybody look different what
did they do today it's really hilarious
because what's up guys one of my
favorite sponsors of the show better
help
what interferes with your happiness so
many things
so many things guys depression stress
anxiety like we're still in the pandemic
we're still dealing with that it's
affecting our sleep it's affecting our
mood and sometimes you need some extra
help and that's what better help is all
about you can connect connect with a
safe
private
environment
it's really easy it's convenient
you can start communicating with under
48 hours and by the way it's not a
crisis line that's important to point
out it's not self-help this is
professional counseling done securely
online you get timely thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions everything's
confidential obviously and it's
convenient it's professional it's
affordable
um i swear by therapy i mean i love the
process of therapy i just think that you
know a lot of people there's a stigma on
therapy that you think that it's going
to solve your problems or it's going to
no no sometimes you just need to connect
the dots and you know who helps you
connect those dots as a professional
that recognizes patterns
that can ask you the questions that
you've never thought to ask and it's
going to help you maybe not solve the
problem but it's maybe it's going to
help you recognize it and then you can
see why you're doing the things that
you're doing you just get to the core of
stuff so look i want you to start living
a happier life today and as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp.help.com
griffin for 10 off your first month
what's up guys let's continue to talk
about liquid iv liquid iv is great you
know it's great for hydration it's great
it gives you those electrolytes and all
that stuff that helps you i use it
i use it in the mornings when i work out
now because i just got this rowing
machine so i'm really getting into that
and sometimes you need more than just
water and you get to like really it
really helps you with that you know so
it's before a workout and even after the
workout and it's good for daily
hydration
the taste is good too they got a lot of
great flavors they got lemon lime
strawberry watermelon passion fruit
guava pina colada
immune boost in in
support in the tangerine i mean it's
really great so i really highly
recommend you using liquid iv uh you
know just make it more than water you
know you throw this stuff in there and
especially when you're feeling
dehydrated if you're like going through
the day you're not drinking enough water
and you just want to get like just you
want to get a little boost from more
than just like one cup of water liquid i
v it contains five essential vitamins
more vitamin c than and then an orange
and much more potassium than a banana
healthier than sugary sports drinks no
artificial flavors or preservatives and
less sugar than an apple made with clean
ingredients no gmo vegan
and free of gluten dairy and soy
it's just effective what makes it
effective is its cellular transport
technology grab your liquid iv flavors
nationwide at walmart or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code griffin at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code griffin
at liquid
iv.com i
i
we stopped specifically on a day on a
scene where i left and then i come back
from class or whatever i was 30 pounds
heavier of muscle i was tan because i
had just gone to jamaica
my hair was lighter because i i lived in
new york for six months and it was dark
but then i obviously was in l.a for you
know that seven eight months my hair got
lighter from the sun and i showed up and
i had like blonde hair so i left the
scene and then i come back like yeah
what's good like what happened and i'm
like everything's different but you
can't really tell they get it they did
like a solid job what are they gonna do
like they just go everybody knows yeah
they just put on the screen covet
[ __ ] yeah yeah who has it yeah yeah
yeah but the thing that i can't get on
board with is the [ __ ] the mass in
covid in the shows it's like nobody
wants to watch us everyone [ __ ] hates
it all day long and seeing what they
they don't want to watch it on tv did
you did you see that brian cranston
showtime show oh i know did you see
there was one scene in it that took me
out so much there was the one lady in
the um
uh in the courtroom and she had a mascot
no one else had a mask on and then brian
cranston goes um oh we should go into
the quarters alone so we can social
distance i'm like you didn't bring up
kovid for nine episodes and all of a
sudden you're gonna bring it up for four
minutes and then one lady has a mascot
billions did the same thing it took me
out yeah billions did the same thing but
i actually like how they did it they did
it
they did it where like the main guy
he got coveted and like he's
quarantining so they got him like he's
doing all this stuff from like an office
and everybody's zooming and all this
kind of stuff and i was kind of like
okay
but it's like and then like another show
i like is a good doctor uh-huh i love
the good doctor it makes me cry every
time
it's a medical show i don't know but
here's the thing though so the first two
episodes that came back after kovitz it
was all coveted yeah it was like oh the
code and it was like so heavy-handed
yeah they did it for two episodes and
then after that they put up a disclaimer
like you know i hope everybody's safe
and blah blah blah blah but we're like
we're basically we're moving on in our
universe oh nice where cova doesn't
exist
i like that you know and so then it was
just like normal that's what happened to
me three months after the pandemic
happened i put a disclaimer up when i
woke up and i was like oh that doesn't
exist anymore
but it's like but it's just like i know
what you're saying though yeah so it's
just like the connors like like on the
street they're all wearing mask on the
on the billboards it's like people don't
people want to when they watch tv to get
away from they escape they want to
escape it's like and everything nowadays
it's like okay i understand some things
want to have a message and but it's like
everything is so political and this and
that and
people don't they deal with it all
[ __ ] day long on instagram on social
media they just want their job yeah they
want to watch their favorite show they
go to restaurants when they go to get it
i don't want to see my favorite show be
like oh my this you mean this fictional
character is also dealing with what i'm
dealing with yeah yeah it's like show
him [ __ ] shooting someone in the head
and robbing this place yeah if you're
gonna have people wearing masks on tv
then have ugly people too yeah yeah
exactly yeah i agree with that well no
when i'm watching when i'm watching like
csi
like yeah i want my csi agent to be hot
yeah yeah yeah i don't need real life if
i want real life i like also
every person who works fast food on tv
beautiful like where the [ __ ] is this
yeah what world is it so it's like we
look for this is an escape it's escapism
so if i can't have escapism because they
also acting like it's oh and then
shooting stuff it's like such a
nightmare i did a pilot
oh he did a pilot eric did a didn't even
get picked up i don't have an aston
martin outside how dare you yeah okay so
i did a pilot and what a nightmare it
was to shoot why it was action
first of all the um it was an abc show
so it was a sitcom so first um yeah i'm
not gonna be a drug dealer i guess i
could you know
our show is younger skewed so there's a
little bit more comedy than this than
seriously okay well then you need to
like hit that i'll see what i get
casting personally i'll see you guys
yeah jesus
jesus christ who are you i want young
white girls calling me like oh my god
that girl is actually black
what yeah she didn't sound like it
she's from atlanta what do you mean oh
so you got a lot of black girls in
atlanta now
that's all i got
what do you think do you think anyone
watching riverdale is dming me
i got the girls who watch [ __ ] empire
and bmf and you know uh all your phone
is like tanisha
yeah yeah i i'm not kidding i'm hanging
out with adisha tonight like i'm not
playing oh wow look look what y'all done
where's the cassie what's what what's up
with your you got to get him on
riverdale yeah
no she needs to get me with you know who
uh hallie bailey is yeah oh she needs to
get me with her have you seen her she is
beautiful oh you're too much
am i wrong so are you oh wait are you
trying to level up now i mean i was
trying to level up but uh well i'm
trying to level up i like this so you're
on tv now she's like so all the other
basic girls you've been talking to
you're kind of like yeah she's not
hallelujah how many followers you got on
instagram
are you like that now you flying into
the they gotta have a check mark dm well
they have to have the check mark but the
followers doesn't matter
wow
you you literally ain't [ __ ] now
who are you yeah i'm just playing i'm
just just playing you have a great
personality
you are lying where'd you meet your
girlfriend now i've seen this out of
your business don't try to flip this
i've seen you on rhea i'm not gonna i've
seen you on raya that was a long ass
time ago
look at him you know he got his raya
profile oh yeah dude are you kidding me
i'm [ __ ] i think i heard a buzz over
here i was like
oh my god anyways
anyways to get back to it yeah hey shows
stop with that stop with the covet but i
was like i'm saying i was doing this
pilot and
with a nightmare all the auditions
zoom
oh listen the test thank god i haven't
had zoom which i had to do three times
the table read
zoom yeah we did zoomtextual network
table reading
yeah we haven't met each other
like i haven't stand next to this woman
who's supposed to be my wife on this
show we don't even know like
and then you shoot it and it's weird we
we got together for the first time when
we're shooting and i was like oh my god
hey yeah i don't know anything i don't
know i've been married to you for 40
years but i don't know and then the
protocols you know like yeah it's the
worst such a nightmare just like you
know this and nothing it's like the
thing that blows my mind is the um masks
on for rehearsal
mask off for the scene bro as if cove is
going to be like they should i do that i
do this all the time i do this all the
time i walk in a set and they'll be like
mask on for for rehearsal it'll just be
like me and michael my co-star and i was
like actually can we just bring the
camera in here and turn it on so covet
goes away because it's just like what
are we doing i know it's a dog and pony
show because it's all about liability
yeah yeah they have to show that they're
doing something which is really
bothersome to me yeah it's bothersome to
me because i feel like well
like then it's like do you really care
about health and safety yeah it's just
it's it's a performative i always say
man i'd sign a waiver yeah wouldn't you
sign a waiver a hundred and ten percent
like like just go i can't get covered by
the way i cannot get covet why not i
literally cannot get covered i promise
you i have gone to in a week i know uh
eric yeah yeah i have gone everywhere
during the pandemic whatever i get
tested every other day for work cannot
get covered i hung out with a girl she
slept over
you know whatever uh the next morning
she went to her job which she also
needed to get tested for covet she had
coveted all night whatever i didn't get
it my my whole family had covet twice
with me in the house nothing with me
it's crazy i'm like immune to it i think
i have the blood type that can't get
into the immunity yeah you know i feel
sometimes i feel like that too because i
have did you get it no
i haven't gotten it either i've been
tested like a bunch of times too you
know and i saw who knows but who knows
they cut to both of us like yeah i know
the omni crumb yeah yeah whatever it is
but yeah that zoom audition is crazy
like i i couldn't imagine reading for a
casting director like that like even if
it's going in and out i'm like thank god
i'm offer only i don't have to do that
but it was like it was like oh this
you see how you slip that in you see how
he slipped that in oh my god
okay
all right
you don't think you don't you don't
think tarantino gonna have you come over
yeah
although i did see oliver stone at a
house party the other night and it was
wild i'm like i cannot believe this guy
oh you're at oliver stone house parties
i was at a kennedy house party weird
brag but yeah oliver stone was there i
was like this is crazy oh that through
theo cause i know you just actually
wasn't dude but bill burr was there and
and uh he actually yeah bobby just came
on um
this past weekend i don't work with this
past weekend anymore but it was actually
was just like a coincidence that i went
to um his house and you know theo was he
just had him on the podcast and stuff
like that oh that's cool yeah yeah it's
like um that's a weird world too thank
god that the podcasting was going like i
i started gaming and yeah podcasting
stuff
really helped me and especially that's
where the entertainment industry is
going anyways it's kind of going away of
like these you know leonardo dicaprio
type people and it's more going towards
like the kids who have ticked the kids
who have youtube the kids who do twitch
and stuff like that i don't know i think
so i think it's just another branch of
entertainment but it's not taking over
entertainment yeah i don't think agree i
don't think it's taking over but the
kids who were there there are getting
this stuff like they're like well does
he have a big following is he gonna sell
the movie like that's a lot of it it is
i i i
they say that but i don't believe you
don't think so no because because and i
know this because these tick tock stars
tell me a movie that's starring a tic
toc star i mean that new addison ray uh
netflix movie that came out oh
netflix could do anything they want yeah
there's a bunch of [ __ ] on netflix too
yeah but i mean like is it a hit is it
the number one movie on netflix like
naming one like name me one show that's
starring a tick tock star like they have
to be able to act they're
agreed but there's a guy on our show
who's i think one of the best actors on
our show he's incredible he was a social
media star yeah there's obviously people
like that king batch went to agree
he was a classically trained actor yeah
so it's easy he just found this medium
and he you know he attacked that medium
too but what i'm saying is these people
that are started that way yeah it don't
translate agreed yeah they don't
translate these people that watch these
like social media people they're not
watching them yeah for
for for an hour and 15 minutes or hour
and 45 minute movie they don't terrible
they're not watching them for that they
just say please be cute yeah and make me
laugh for like 20 seconds so i can move
on to the next thing you know what i
mean that's it's not so i know they say
that they say that i i just think
because they try i think it's going more
in that direction where you'll get more
jobs if you're if you're full if you
have those types of things like if
you're an actor like like we'll see what
you see will smith and jack black doing
[ __ ] youtube vlogs and tick tocks
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
they already built agreed that's but
that's what i'm saying no but that but
my what i'm trying to tell you is that's
what's wrong with this process
they're saying to you hey
without us
become famous yeah and then we're gonna
take you that's not how it was supposed
to work yeah okay fair it's not supposed
to work like that it's supposed to be
like hey we found this talented kid and
we're going to introduce this talented
kid to the world then the world decides
we like him yeah and now we're going to
follow
this [ __ ] is flipped on its head yeah
like what yeah
okay that's interesting yeah i didn't
think of it like that yeah it's like
what are you talking about like it's
about talent and it's the reason why
these people aren't like there isn't one
like where you go oh that person started
on whatever yeah
you can't name me a movie a tv show
there that's the kid everyone comments
on like i can't believe he started from
tickets
not the rule it's fair exception not the
rule and i think that i and i think that
like there was a time where they thought
oh man regular tv is going to go away
yeah youtube yeah never
never
no kid in their garage is going to be
better than the production value of
power yeah or any show that people
actually watch right you know what i'm
saying there's just way more that goes
into it there's way more that goes
through there's way more talented people
who have done this for a while yeah yeah
yeah you're not gonna it's not gonna be
taken it hasn't happened yet and it
never will happen it's just another
branch of media in the same way like you
know all of this all the the online
stuff it's like it's like you know so
you have like so now we used to go
theater movies tv
now it's social media yeah it's just an
extra branch it's just an extra branch
okay i say it's just
but i just think that what
they just complement each other if you
have a good social media it's gonna help
that's right you have a good youtube
it's just gonna help everything so i
just feel like that's the direction it's
gonna be going it's like they want you
to have it all they don't want you to
read the guy just that's on this i know
but we're talking about the origin story
like how does this work so it's changing
how we get it eric you're a marvel nerd
the origin story okay i want to just
slap him
[Laughter]
i told you my driver is here today
that one
and tell him the key to the no what i'm
saying though is that
the the how you come go about this so
now it you know you're you're young
you're 19 and you want to be an actor so
now you got to go
not just you got to go to acting class
so now that we're saying to that person
there's young kids out there don't just
go to acting class yeah actually do
stuff on the internet yeah you know so
so you know do scenes on the internet uh
get your personality out there it's just
an added thing that has to be added to
it which wasn't there before agreed you
know what i mean but i think steps are
being skipped and it's not working yeah
agreed i could agree with that you know
what i'm saying so i mean even like with
the translate like like i started just
other podcasts it's called jen to jen i
like that kid i think matthew
yeah and he wants to be an actor too
like actually he he produced and made
his own movie yeah but it wasn't a big
success yeah because it doesn't
translate like even with the podcast
he's got four million followers yeah and
so the thought that they had was like oh
man yeah all those followers are gonna
listen to we're gonna get four million
views an episode yeah yeah they don't
those people that watch him for that
they don't want to listen for an hour
yeah it's just like it's so it's like
there is a disconnect between
social media and traditional media and
the traditional entertainment there is a
disconnect we have to find the through
lines and make it work together but it
it it is a myth to say well you have to
have this yeah because if somebody's got
talent and charisma yeah whatever yeah i
don't think [ __ ] david fincher's
gonna go how many followers okay that's
fair yeah exactly yeah the the stuff
you're talking about that you know the
cool stuff yeah you think they care
about that yeah they actually well does
he have a vlog
come on man you think tarantino's asking
people to be in this movie for that
reason yeah you know it's like come on
man i just think it complimented that
was all i was saying but you're right
yeah that's not how you said it at first
now you you've come to this point no i
just said that it goes it's going more
towards that's what the studio's like
they want people with that are fully
they have i think they're using that as
a way to say no
okay i think that's what we can agree to
disagree yeah i think i think they're
doing that i think they just go
no you know i don't think we really want
i guess you know what i mean that's just
a great now a little check box they can
go yeah perfect yeah oh he only has a
hundred thousand followers oh yeah yeah
yeah do it yeah but they're still making
[ __ ] products yeah it's like these
networks come out they come out dude i
can't believe some of the stuff that's
on tv right now forget about even the
stuff that's not on tv the fact that
they make so many yeah like like in
pilot season you know like they're out
there spending all this money to make
these pilots and they don't even go yeah
and it's like what it's crazy but even
the stuff that makes it to television i
watch some shows and i'm like i cannot
believe a studio green lit this i can't
believe they put millions of dollars
into this it's crazy yeah it's crazy and
i'm not like discrediting anyone's you
know we won't say any names yeah i'm not
i'm not it's not like i'm talking about
eric's pilot but
oh that's my doorbell someone here yeah
probably amazon yeah it's amazon but
that's not crazy anyways i'm not talking
about eric's pilot but i am um it's just
no i but sometimes they make stuff and
it doesn't come out the way that they
that they expect oh dude don't even get
me started on this i mean that that
that's what happened with this they're
not like thinking about oh let's make
this big piece of [ __ ] and see how it
does
they actually this is i just think
there's too many cooks in the kitchen
okay so like the network so like we were
rehearsed
so this is what happened today we
rehearsed we rehearsed for
a week who else starred in that with you
it was a jane lynch oh i love her yeah
but yeah uh nicole richie
anyway
we rehearsed for a week all right and
then we're about to shoot
and the the producer comes over and says
hey uh they want to change all the lines
you know we want to change up because
you know it was something about we it
was about me and the coach nicole
richards was supposed to be my wife
so that was like a whole thing you know
what i mean it was like i had a beer
they wanted me to diet they wanted me
like you know because it's like and
people were gonna buy that
it looks
you know what i mean like
my real fiancee is beautiful as [ __ ] so
she actually is yeah so people will buy
it yeah yeah okay
so it's like
all i'm saying is it's like it's like
like whoever's running it they have
their preconceived notions whatever so
it was the whole thing i had to shave i
had to dye my beard i had to like all
this stuff you know they bought you a
rowing machine
it was like they wanted to be like all
right are you like we need to see that
they're married yeah yeah they kept
changing the lines and i was like what
the woman it's like the network just
wants to do stuff to do stuff yeah i
this is my analogy and i said this
before but i'll say to you it would be
like you want to build a house and it's
all your money i'm the architect
and i sell here's my plans for the house
yeah and you go great
make the house now during the making of
the house you come in and go
ah
can we move the kitchen
yeah
then you're like
can we change yeah can we change this to
italian something yeah and then i build
it and then you look at it and go ah i
don't like this yeah you know why you
don't like it yeah because you [ __ ] it
up
you're right you're right what they
should do is just go we like what you
want to do make what you want to make
here's the money to make the show yeah
if at that point you don't like it yeah
then then you could be like well we
don't like it but if you don't like it
after you tinkered with it yeah yeah
look in the mirror yeah agreed you're
great you're right you're right you're
right
it's just too much
yeah especially with pilots now it's
like if they want to change everything
they want to add the line this and that
that's why i like where what happened
with power is because it just became a
spin-off yeah and then they're like you
already did it so that just go do it and
no one ever like no one ever came up and
says well i don't think your character
would do that they're like well you know
it you do what you do you know what i
mean which is why i think it's
successful they didn't well it's
different when they allow like creators
to create yeah you know i i think that
those the traditional networks don't do
they just don't do it they're they're
just stars stars is very good with that
star is very good all of those networks
yeah like that you know what i mean it's
like they're all that's why some of them
like the rent like showtime or hbo
they'll have a really good show and it's
like yeah well they just let the creator
do what they wanted to do like what
happened with sure they have notes but
at the same time it's not as like yeah
there isn't these people trying to
justify their job well that [ __ ] that
squid game show that guy got told no
by like 15 networks for for years for 20
years he was like i was trying to get
the maid try to get this may try this
because made and they would not make it
and then finally netflix was like yes
make it do what you want to do with it
and it's the most watched show of all
time
yeah it's crazy it's like and and every
network pass on him at like every year
every network pass in him they're like
no we we don't want to do this i know
and it's like you wonder like why do
those people have jobs
like they're so it's out of touch it's
yeah it's just like as if
they they came up and they're like oh i
wanted to be an actor and then it didn't
work out for them i want to be a writer
it didn't work out from there like okay
well let me just go to a network and
they never got anything that was
successful so they're just like oh well
um we don't like this and it's like okay
i don't even know i i actually think
it's so much tinkering
so much like people's opinion about
stuff
and it's just it's just you just go oh
man i remember like during the making it
as pilot
do an audition where'd you shoot where'd
you shoot at it was at radford oh cool
you know so we were uh because the
people that made the connors so we
actually shot on the connor set nice so
they um
i remember the the the producers said
you know what i i need i'm thinking like
the network right now and let's do this
yeah and i thought oh yeah yeah like
whatever that means yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you know what i mean like i'm thinking
like the network yeah how about you
think like they're people that like
watching tv exactly how about those
people yeah cause those are the people
but everything's so oh man i don't know
you don't watch
are you not a marvel person at all i do
but
it's just not my like i try to get into
it so hard but i just can't and it's not
a nerd i watched the spider-man one uh
with tom holland and i like that and i
think
okay you're not really into it you don't
like that no no i'm saying i'm just
saying yuck to you um
uh like this movie eternals came out uh
i heard it terrible right
regardless to me it was like it's such a
sign of the times like you know because
in the eternals these these beings are
supposed to be seven thousand years old
created by the celestial power person
who created these things and they're now
on earth to like you know fight the bad
guys and they're gender fluid and
were they actually bro
gay black guy
deaf girl
a latino woman yeah two asians yeah you
know and then two white people who are
the bad guys
so so i'm like i'm like
what are we doing yeah like what are we
doing like i'm i'm of an age where i
could like i see this and i go what the
hell is this yeah there are young people
who might be like oh this is great you
know yeah they don't even but for me i
see it and i go what are we doing yeah
just the logic of it don't make sense to
me yeah why would
yeah why would a gay black guy be
friends with a deaf latino yeah not even
no why would this why would they create
them like that and send them here for 7
000 years yeah you know what i mean oh i
see what you're saying yeah so just the
logic of like forget the social stuff of
it yeah if i'm just being a nerd yeah
this don't make sense yeah okay i know
what you mean yeah it don't make sense
yeah this is some woke nonsense
for who
yes i'm okay
but i like the like the representation
is great like i don't i don't have any
any knock with that like of course no
problem with representation yeah but it
should make sense agreed that's that's
what i was going to get to it should
make sense yeah it's like it'd be like
if this is victorian england the butler
is the butler black or like or like not
even the butler because the butler could
be black yeah let's say like the guy
that lives in the castle next door for
some reason now that's a black guy yeah
would that make sense
it's not historically accurate yeah but
for you know that's why i felt like i
remember watching beauty and the beast
and i was like what yeah like wait wait
because you the character was gay i was
like where are these where these seven
black people come from
yeah in this like 12th century black
black this 12th century white village
yeah all of a sudden so you just go all
right so for me i just go i get why they
do it yeah it's like so there's people
that are like hey representation yeah
and then i'm just kind of like they say
historically accurate yeah okay yeah
okay so yeah if it's a story all right
did you see the new gossip girl
oh don't even give me my girl loves
gossip but here's the thing because i i
wanted to be on that show no i was i was
already doing power um i was booked in
business the kind of show you're talking
about though exactly so like that's the
kind of show that i look like that i
would be honest i would be the bully
that bully's the gay kid
named the chick named lindsay would have
called you yeah yeah
[Music]
then their call would be from ashley
yeah you know um but so i went to like
the premiere and i watched it and i
didn't have any
i think that you and i are starting to
get older because
the other people that were watching like
everyone was non-binary hooking up there
was there was
there was yeah there was like bisexual
threesomes and one guy was uh queer and
all that stuff and i um i was like kind
of like is oh this is like confusing
like they're if they're just all okay
with [ __ ] each other and she's
[ __ ] him and she's yeah yeah
and then everyone's like loving it and
eating it up and i'm like i think i'm
getting older but here's the thing
i'm fine with everything that's
happening on gossip girl i'm fine
because that's the sign of the time yeah
that's what i'm saying so this is like
that's the sign of the type that's
accurate yeah these are rich people that
live in doing rich people stuff yeah
yeah okay it's rich people doing rich
people stuff and there are rich
ethnic people of course and that's what
this is yeah so you go in that situation
you're like cool yeah eternals not cool
okay i seriously that's what i'm saying
yeah i just i just mean i think you and
i are getting older because everyone is
fine with all that stuff and i was like
i just thought it was it's strange i'm
like is this how the world is in high
school now yeah that's what came to mind
oh well yeah of course yeah see now
that's where i'm so far removed from
that age group that what do i know about
like you know because like i come from
an era where it was like we definitely
always thought about race yeah because
it was put in our face all the time i
experienced real racism i experienced
like you know so it was like you know
you you it was very like all tv was
mostly white yeah everything was white
and it was like you know we experienced
that so cut to now here we are these
kids today grew up with a black
president yeah and they're kind of like
uh what are you talking about you know
yeah yeah why don't we we're gender
fluid yeah why do we have to choose what
we want to yeah who we want to have sex
with we want to have a relationship
sometimes i'll watch stuff from like the
90s or like the early 2000s and you know
me and my brothers were sitting there
and you will not see
one black person for like legit two
hours of a movie and we look at each
other and go okay i could see how they
could be upset
i could see how uh this could be a
problem you know what i mean well i mean
i would there even been a show like like
power in the night never yeah well i
mean i mean the wire early early on w
yeah but see that's a show
about black people being criminals okay
yeah i guess well power we're all
criminals boom i love how i wrote myself
in with i'm like yeah all those black
people we're all criminal you know what
i'm saying though is like it's like
where's hypothesis
where's the downtown where's the
downtown abbey for black people yeah
okay i get what you're saying where's
the where's the cool hip show this is
what pisses me off so that's what i'm
saying this is what pisses me off about
award season type [ __ ] is that there
will never be or there hasn't been a
show with that's predominantly black or
predominantly you know a different race
that
actually i'm going to stick with the
with the black thing with the black
culture right now
if it's not about slavery they won't
nominate it because you know what i mean
it because well because every year they
have to have the white guilt movie that
comes out but that's not even what i'm
saying it's like if it's a video i don't
need to be reminded but but if it's
about shooting in guns and drugs it
could be the best show in the world
they're like uh well that's not moving
it's not you know what i mean but then
like a show
like the sopranos it's all you know what
i mean that'll get nominated every time
i just think that it's like okay well
this is moving and it's about racism and
and you know what i mean that's what i
don't like is like power those shows
should be nominated but they never do
and i think that we're in uh um
i don't know man i mean we're just in a
different era right now we're trying to
find
yeah the people are trying to find
themselves and figure out like if things
aren't normalized yet so it's like we're
so i always look at sports you have to
look at sports look at basketball
a hundred years ago it was all white
okay
crazy i couldn't imagine how shitty it
was
so then it was all white and then then
they then college there was a certain
time in the 60s or wherever that
whatever that was that somebody decided
you know what let's let some black
people play yeah and then it was then
they it started like that and then cut
to
you know cut to the nba you know when
the nba was
mostly white
then it was
some black yeah now it's mostly black
yeah
all white coaches
then they let
then there's now there's black coaches
then it was all white gms
now there's some black gm's okay then
there's one black owner
so
that shows you how long it takes yeah to
integrate it okay that's how long it
takes it takes generations yeah
unfortunately yeah so i went i went to a
um a nets game a couple weeks ago in
brooklyn quartzite
um and uh i saw one white guy out there
and i was like i was kind of rooting for
him a little bit it was it was one guy
out there in the whole team and i was
like just do us proud you know what i
mean it wasn't like a like a pr like a
pride thing it was just like just just
don't embarrass me when you see somebody
that looks like you you want that person
to be successful yeah yeah i was like
yeah and then and then i saw james
harden dunk over him and i was like this
is this is not going good for us well i
mean it's like and then but by the way
that was probably somebody that's not
even from the united states i mean you
couldn't name yeah you can't name me
five american-born white basketball
players that start in the nba i couldn't
yeah go you guys at home go ahead
nash go ahead
canada
oh [ __ ]
jason kidd
jason kidd is he's mixed
is he yeah and he doesn't play anymore
yeah that's it for me
all i know is nba live oh six that's
that's my that was my lineup that's all
i [ __ ]
all i'm saying is like so that's like a
thing anyway so it's just you know it
just takes all i'm saying is it takes a
generation so you look at entertainment
it's the same kind of thing it's just
going to take some time so here we are
like we're noticing it because we're
seeing the switch and it's just
uncomfortable for older people yeah but
like you look at a show like gossip girl
and it's like who cares you know it's
like you got this bald girl who's like
non whatever and she's yeah i didn't
have any grips i was just looking around
and like i'm just like because you're
noticing it because it's something
that's not familiar exactly that's all
it's going to take it's just going to
take
more time yeah as more time passes yeah
you know we're going to just be like
it's not going to be a thing we even
think about but right now we're still
thinking about it because when you turn
on tv it's still predominantly white
yeah but again
you know that's just a business thing
too the middle of the country is
predominantly white yeah when they turn
on the tv they maybe they want to see
white faces yeah maybe they want to see
people that look like them they want to
see people they can relate to all right
i i you know i don't know what the thing
is but there is a money factor in there
that goes into like
like when you look at the commercials
like you know like you know uh who who
are these commercials for like when you
look at daytime tv it's all women yeah
they they're all every commercials for
women it's like tampons and blah blah
are you saying because they're all
staying home other men are working is
that where you were getting at is that
what you said time stamped that
i thought that's what you were saying i
don't know because that's they've
they've looked at the studies yeah
predominantly during the day yeah we're
going to watch tv yeah
they're watching soap operas they're
watching the view they're watching the
real
they're watching all these shows and
these are the shows and there's four
women so the commercial should be for
women agreed so therefore that's the way
the networks work yeah so therefore if
the commercial if the shows are
for white people yeah yeah then again
the commercials are gonna be for white
you know i mean maybe that's how they
think about it maybe it's an archaic
thought and they should change it
because it's crazy when these like uh
predominantly black shows come on the
air how well they do power is one of the
most watched
it's like it's like i don't know if
they're looking at the numbers do these
network types look at the algorithms and
stuff like empire was like the biggest
show in fox's history i didn't want to
hear that word
i'm just saying at the time it was like
that was a thing and by the way why do
they have to be in competition exactly
well also 50 does few that a little bit
because they're they're in a
conversational and he's like ah empire's
trap and it gets impressed but yeah
they're in competition because that's
what they they're like oh they're a
black shirt oh [ __ ] yeah it's like
they're not even
remotely like none of these other shows
all these white shows are never like oh
that other white
shirt the connors aren't mad at like
whatever others you know they're just
like oh
we're just on yeah you know what i mean
yeah and so again once that feeling goes
away
then we'll we're going to be more in
line to be like oh this is great now
like when people aren't even yeah they
don't think about it yeah well they're
not even thinking about it but you know
unfortunately we're still thinking about
it
let me see where we're at
what does that say to the time
55 minutes uh
look at that see we're right on schedule
um
what's up shawty okay my bad yeah just
text me
yeah who are you now
is texting you're
[Laughter]
look like i
i just love black like i like black
women like it's just okay
you don't got to feel like no i'm just
justified i know but i'm just saying
like it's not like i'm like oh my dpms
are you don't even lost half your fan
base but go ahead
i was just saying like it's not like i'm
like yeah you know it's like all the
king and the sting and theo bonds fans
just turned on you
he likes me he likes black people yeah
theo just turned it in grave right now
[Music]
out there good for you he was on the
real girl he was on the reel
that was him on the reel
what did you do
they probably oh it's always just like
you're so cute yeah i do get a lot but
it is great lonnie's cute i think and
i've known lonnie for years shout out to
ronnie i think she's uh you know she's
lonnie if you're single you never know
um
you heard it here first
i'm gonna use this as the clip for the
episode
i'm [ __ ] done after this oh my god
you're not yeah we have a huge
discussion but listen check out uh mr
gianni piallo right right yeah paolo p.a
didn't say it right but it's p p paolo
yeah so it's like pay olo yeah so like
if there's a dude named olo you gotta
pay him exactly yo pay olo
i got it
oh there's my girls here gianni paolo
who's my driver or my assistant which
one or my publicist which one is it
shut up dude
so stupid
no but thank you yeah for real thank you
for listening and
check out what's uh power ghost yeah
power power book two ghosts on stage oh
power book this is coming out today
stars it's gonna come well yeah so
today's monday uh we filmed it uh i got
the notes from the publicist
so basically the whole conversation
there's four minutes in the beginning
where i'm like yeah power's been good
and there's this ending
and then eric chopped up me being like
black people are good
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
ah but anyways um thanks for being here
dude and congratulations thank you no
for you too man no no no listen i love
watching my kingdom singing now whatever
this is about you no it's not about me
it's about us congratulations i like
seeing the growth i actually really did
when i was looking at the the instagram
post and i and i saw that aston martin
to me it was more it was more of a sign
of like
progress yeah more of a sign of like
moving forward it's like you know you
know what i mean it's like oh that's
that's you know no matter what happens
yeah you can always look back and be
like yeah i did at least i did it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and even your
kids are like dude we have a minivan why
don't we have it
it's like your life like shut the [ __ ]
up yeah
your life moves how it moves yeah and
there's nothing you can really do about
that so it's like live your best life uh
you know i'm glad you're putting money
away too though yeah but there is a
middle ground and i'm glad that you're
doing that and i wish you all the
success
i love you i'll come back you know i
want to come on i'll come on jen to jen
when i come back afterwards
we're still trying to figure out like
what we're trying to do with it uh you
know because it's like we have guests
that don't have guests and it's like i
try to tell him we need to establish our
report yeah so we're doing that but
check that out also check me out on
twitch every daily twitch eric griffin
gaming i'm going to have all of your
uh gianni's uh socials down below black
girls reach out in mdm's
[Laughter]
he will hit you back
asap
all the issues
[Laughter]
all the anya's and all that stuff
anybody any name like that jackson's
johnsons please hit hit him up to the
dms and check him out on power on stars
that's every sunday right yep every
sunday comes out saturday night at
midnight and then you can watch it on
sunday boom so check that out on stars
and this has been riffing with griffin
and thanks for being here bro thanks
eric i appreciate you having me i love
you guys next week
you